>> Laura: WE TOLD YOU LAST
NIGHT ABOUT A SHOCKING REPORT
THAT FOUND THAT LAWS LEGALIZING
MARIJUANA HAVE NOT DRIVEN
ORGANIZED CRIME OUT OF THE POT
TRADE, JUST THE OPPOSITE.
THEY HAVE CREATED A HUGE GOLD
RUSH.
OUR GUEST MAKES INVERT OF THE
MARIJUANA POLICY PROJECT
DISAGREES.
>> STATES LIKE COLORADO,
WASHINGTON AND CALIFORNIA, AND
WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS, THE
DEMAND AMONGST THE POPULATION IN
THOSE STATES IS BEING MET BY A
NEW LEGAL MARKET, WHERE THE
PRODUCT IS BEING CONTROLLED.
IT'S BEING GROWN AND SOLD BY
LICENSED BUSINESSES.
>> Laura: IF THAT STATEMENT
REALLY IRKED SHERIFF PHIL ELDER
OF EL PASO COUNTY IN COLORADO
AND HE JOINS US NOW FROM DENVER.
SHERIFF, YOU ARE ON THE FRONT
LINE.
YOU SEE THE RESULTS OF POT
LEGALIZATION.
I HAVE BEEN A STAUNCH CRITIC OF
THIS MOVE TO LEGALIZE DRUGS FOR
YEARS NOW.
YOU SEE THE MONEY IN IT, IT'S
HUGE MONEY.
CORPORATIONS AND LOBBYISTS ARE
SWARMING ALL OVER WASHINGTON.
I WANT TO PLAY FOR YOU WHAT
CHUCK SCHUMER SAID ABOUT THIS.
>> I STUDIED THE ISSUE AND WE
NOW HAVE SOME EVIDENCE.
THE STATE OF WASHINGTON AND
OTHER STATES, WHERE IT HAS DONE
LOTS OF GOOD AND NO HARM.
THE JUSTICE BRANDEIS SAID, LET
THE STATES THE LABORATORIES.
THE EXPERIMENT HAS BEEN A
SUCCESS, LET'S NATIONALIZE IT.
>> HE DOESN'T WANT THE STATES TO
BE LABORATORIES OF PRO-LIFE
LEGISLATION, HOWEVER.
SHERIFF?
>> IT HAS BEEN A GRAND
EXPERIMENT.
WE HAVE TAKEN COLORADO AND WE
HAVE OPENED THE FLOODGATES, AND
NOW WE HAVE BLACK MARKET
MARIJUANA EVERYWHERE.
>> Laura: AND IT WAS SAID
YESTERDAY THAT, THE ONLY REASON
THIS IS HAPPENING,
SHERIFF ELDER, IT'S BECAUSE ALL
THE OTHER STATES HAVE A NEED FOR
THE POT.
YOU CAN'T BUY IT IN ALL THE
OTHER STATES WHERE IT'S NOT
LEGAL.
AND ONCE IT'S LEGALIZE
NATIONALLY, THEN THE CARTELS
WILL MOVE OUT.
DO YOU BUY THAT ARGUMENT?
>> NOT AT ALL.
THE CARTELS HAVE INFILTRATED
COLORADO RIGHT AND LEFT.
RIGHT NOW WE ARE TRACKING OVER
600 GROWS IN EL PASO COUNTY
ALONE, WITH ANOTHER 150 OR 200
IN PUEBLO COUNTY THAT ARE ALL
CARTEL CONTROLLED BLACK MARKET
MARIJUANA.
THAT MARIJUANA IS BEING PACKAGED
AND SOLD ALL OVER THE EAST COAST
AT TWO OR TWO AND A HALF TIMES
ITS VALUE IN COLORADO.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
>> Laura: THEY SAY, ONCE ALL
THESE OTHER STATES LEGALIZE IT
IT, -- IT'S DRIVEN BY THE DESIRE
AND THE MARKET.
THE MARKET DEMANDS THAT POT IS
SENT ALL OVER THE COUNTRY AND
ALL THESE OTHER STATES NEED TO
GET WITH IT.
I WILL SHOW THESE BUREAU
STATISTICS THAT THEY MAY NOT SEE
ANYONE ELSE.
HERE'S THE CHANGING CRIME FROM
2013-2016 DURING THE
LEGALIZATION.
IN COLORADO.
COLORADO WAS UP 5%, NATIONALLY
IT WAS DOWN 9%.
VIOLENT CRIME, SAME PERIOD,
COLORADO OF 12.5%, AND
NATIONALLY UP A 5% CORRESPONDING
TO THE PERIODS OF LEGALIZATION.
DOES THAT COMPORT WITH YOUR OWN
EXPERIENCE WITH THE VIOLENT
CRIME INCREASE, SHERIFF?
>> IT ABSOLUTELY DOES.
WE HAVE NOW LEGALIZE MARIJUANA
FOR MEDICINAL USES, AS WELL AS
RECREATIONAL USES.
WE DIDN'T PUT ANY CAPS ON IT.
BEFORE YOU COULD GROW UP TO 99
PLANTS IN A RESIDENTIAL ZONE AND
TODAY WE HAVE LIMITED DATA TO 12
PLANTS AND EVERY ONE OF THESE
GROWS THAT WE HAVE TAKEN DOWN
SINCE THE FIRST OF THE YEAR HAS
HAD WELL OVER 100 PLANTS.
SINCE THE FIRST OF THE YEAR, WE
HAVE EXECUTED 64 SEARCH WARRANTS
AND RECOVERED ALMOST 5300
MARIJUANA PLANTS THAT WERE
DESTINED FOR THE EAST COAST.
THIS IS NO LONGER AN EXPERIMENT.
>> Laura: AS OF THIS IS
CHINESE, MEXICAN AND CUBAN, A
LOT OF THE CARTELS.
IS THAT RIGHT?
>> ALONG WITH SOME LOCATIONS IN
SOUTHERN COLORADO.
>> Laura: AND A PARTRIDGE IN A
PEAR TREE.
THIS IS ABOUT HUGE MONEY, THE
TOBACCO INDUSTRY MOVING INTO THE
POT INDUSTRY, AND APPARENTLY WE